landscape with the fall of Icarus is a
large painting from the 1560s that hangs
in Belgium's largest museum the museum
bazaar and is held to be a meticulous
copy of an original work now lost by the
Flemish artist Pieter Bruegel the elder
the painting shows a superficially
bucolic scene ships are taking sale a
shepherd is tending to his flock distant
cities look prosperous and ordered but
in the bottom right hand corner of the
canvas but tragedy is unfolding all but
unheeded reckless Icarus the legendary
figure from classical mythology is in
the final stages of one of the ancient
world's most famous aeronautical
disasters together with his father
Daedalus the young man had made himself
a pair of wings glued together with wax
Daedalus had warned his son not to fly
too close to the Sun in case its Heat
were to melt the structure but the
impetuous boy soared
too high anyway and in the painting has
just tumbled down into the waves to his
death Icarus is and is deliberately not
the central focus of the painting the
eye is drawn instead to the glittering
cities and smart ships in the distance
as if to emphasize the point the
ploughman at the center of the painting
references a popular proverb no plough
stops for the dying man this neglect of
Icarus is tragedy is at one level
terrifying and sad we read into it how
little the world cares about our own
pains and yet from another perspective
this neglect is deeply gratifying and
importantly redemptive it is one of the
central sources of our unhappiness that
we spend so much of our lives fearing
for our reputations and wondering what
others will think of us when we fail as
we inevitably will at points the
slightest change in our image in the
eyes of others can obsess us we lie
awake at night wondering how we could
cope without the approval of people we
don't even like very much we surrender
our freedom to the verdicts of strangers
but the painters stroke of consoling
genius is here
to show us how when we really mess up
almost no one will be looking or caring
very much the farmer is too busy plowing
the Shepherd is too taken up with
thinking about the weather someone else
is overwhelmingly intent on fishing our
tragedies don't occupy society the way
we fear they will a few people might
notice for a moment then swiftly move on
to the next thing we are at the center
of the galaxy only in our own tortured
Minds the world is still filled with
humans who haven't heard of us and never
will those who might be angry or
disappointed with you now will have
forgotten all about you soon enough your
disgrace will in time be subsumed within
the larger amnesia of a consolingly
indifferent world
it isn't just Icarus who is being
swallowed up and obscured by the waves
some of the same obscurity awaits our
greatest errors and embarrassments we
hope you enjoyed this film for more from
the School of Life you can subscribe to
our Channel and take a look at our range
of products on our website
you